[음악]
제가 오늘은
송은이님이 사옥을 매입했다는
기사를 보고 어떻게 신축을 했는지 뭐
어떻게 투자를 했는지 제가 한번 좀
살펴보도록 하겠습니다
우선 시작하기 전에 사옥을 매입한
거에 대해서 아 진짜 진심으로 너무
축하드리고 제가 보니까 그 사업을
2015년도에 설립하셨더라구요 그래서
이때 설립하고 그 다음에 2020년
딱 5년이 지난 이후에 이제 매입을
한 거예요 여러분들 기존의 영상 보신
분들은 알겠지만 그 과밀억제권역 내에
빌딩을 살 때 법인으로 살 때
과민 억제권역 내 본점이 있고
과밀억제권역 내에 부동산을 살 때는
취득세가 중과됩니다
9.4%예요 근데
5년이 지나면
4.6%입니다 그래서 송은이님은 따로
중간은 안 받은 것 같습니다 아마
되게 감회가 새로울 것 같아요
딱 그 시기에 맞춰서 잘 매입하신 거
같고 그 취득세 중과 금액만 봐도
36억 8천이거든요 이게 4.6%
하면은 중간 안 받으면 1억 6천
중과 받으면 3억
4천
차이가 되게 많이 나죠 거의 약 2억
정도납니다 그래서
5년이 지나고
적당한 시기에 그래서
계약을
2020년 12월 17일 날 했어요
잔금을 이제 그 달 28일 날
했는데 대출은 보면은
42억
채권 최고액이 있고 그 다음에 그
이후에 아마 공사대금 대출을 받은 거
같아요 시설 자금 대출 아무래도
법인으로 매입하고 그 다음에
재무제표가 어느 정도 나와 있어
가지고 대출이 좀 굉장히 잘 나왔던
것 같습니다
매입은 36억 8천에 있고 그 다음에
취득세는 중가가 안 돼서 한 1억
7천 정도 들어가는데
중개수수료랑 관련해서 한 약 한 2억
정도 들어간 것 같습니다 그래서
매입가는 38억 8천 아니냐 39억
정도든 거 같아요 그리고 대출을 그
시설 자금까지 56억을 받았어요 아
지금 대지면 가격이 412
제곱미터에요 412 제곱미터
하면
124평입니다 대지가 그래서 총
3필지 신축한 거고 그 다음에
연면적인
땅이 크다 보니까 굉장히 커요 그래서
한 370평 정도 그래서 뭐 그때
당시가 지금보다는 공사비용이 좀
저렴하긴 했지만 그래도 한창 좀
오르는 시기여서 제가 봤을 때는 뭐
한 30억 초중반 정도 들어갈 것
같거든요
허가가 2021년 7월 29일이고
착공한게
2021년 8월입니다 그래서 제가
봤을 때는 한 30억 초중반 정도
들어간 거 같아요
그러면
신축비
용이 한 30 그냥 뭐 32억 대략
잡을게요
매입을 39억에 있고 그 다음에 신축
비용이나요 정도 들어갔다라고 하면은
한 71억 신축 비용 넉넉잡아 한
35억 보겠습니다
74억 정도
74억에
56억을 빼면은
현금이 한 18억 이 정도 들어간 거
같아 실제 현금이 근데 신축 비용
이거보다 다 더 낮았을 거예요 한
30억 좀 안 들었을 수도 있고
현금 한 10억 중반 중후반 정도로
신축까지 비용이
들어간 것 같습니다 그래서
건축물대장을 일단 좀 더 보자면 지금
3종 일반주거지역이고 건폐율 거의
50% 다 받았고 그 다음에 용적률도
뭐 250% 거의 다 많았습니다
그리고 건물 높이도 21m면은 지금
여기 지상 6층 건물인데
그래도 시원시원하게 되게 잘 뺀 거
같아요 보통은요
정도까지는 안 되거든요 이거보다
작거나 그런 경우가 많은데 11m
하면 그래도 좀 층고는 잘
시원시원하게 돼 있는 거 같고 그
다음에 지하 1층에 지상 6층 그래서
6층까지 올리니까 뭐 스프링클러도
설치해야 되고 이게 건축비가 더 많이
들어요
5층으로 짓냐 6층으로 짓냐에 따라서
건축비가 또 많이 들거든요 아무래도
4억으로 직접 쓸 예정이라서 좀
비용을 많이 들이지 않았나 네 그렇게
좀 예상하고 있습니다 주차는 이제
자주식으로
8대 아무래도 방송 관련된 뭐
차라든지 뭐 카니발 이런게 또 많이
있을 것 같아서 좀 이렇게 자주식으로
좀 잘 뺀 거 같습니다 그래서 지금
여기 위치가
디지털
미디어시티역에서 거리는 되게
가까워요네 거리는 되게 가까운데
아무래도 방송 관련된
업종이다 보니까 이쪽에 4억을 좀
찾은 거 같아요 그래서 여기 이제
코너 변에 그런 건물이라고 보시면 될
거 같고
총 3필지를
매입해가지고
신축을 한 겁니다 그래서 이거를
매입하기 전에 사진을 한번 볼게요
그래서 지금요 모습 지금 외장재는
라임 스톤을 쓴 거 같아요 좀 되게
깔끔하게
신축을 한 거 같고 그 전에는
이거였어요 카페
카페랑 여기 공인중개사사무소 그
다음에요 뒤에는
아마 주택이었을 겁니다 주택
상상이 안 되죠
송은이님이 아마이 상태에서 보셨을 거
아니에요이 허름한 건물 상태에서
그렇게 뭔가 과감하게 투자를
결정했다는 거에 전 되게 좀 높게
평가합니다
현장에 왔을 때 여기 카페랑 그
다음에 옆에 부동산 그리고 뒤에
허름한 주택이 있었을 텐데이 상태에서
뭔가 신축을 해야겠다라고 결심을
맺는 거에 대해서 저는 되게 높게
평가하고 여기 아무래도 땅이 크다
보니까
계단은 아마 가운데 있는 거 같아요
그래서
약간 양옆으로 이렇게 여기가 이제
주차장이고 여기 주차 기둥도 좀
센스있게 잘 하셨네요 여기가 이제
북쪽이어서 여기가 이제 일조권 사선
맞는 부분이고 이쪽에서 보자면 건물
진짜 크고 좋네요 여기 이제 일조권
사선 받은 거고
아무래도 그 업종 특성이 있어서 뭐
창을 그렇게 많이 낸 거 같진
않아요네 일반 오피스 건물보다는
그리고 아무래도 방송 관련된 일이
이런 스튜디오나 이런 거 되어 하는게
또 쉽지 않거든요 막 여기 갔다 저기
갔다
빌려 쓰는 것도 쉽지 않고네 그래서
아마 이쪽 공간에도 좀 그런 부분을
만들어 가지고 뭐 어떻게 보면 회사를
위해서는 되게 좀 제가 봤을 땐 되게
잘한 선택이라고 좀 생각합니다 제가
봤을 땐 여기 또 평당가가 그 사이에
또 많이 오르긴 했거든요 그래서 여기
뭐 기사 보면은 뭐 80억 호가
80억은 넘을 거 같아요 여기 뭐
팔린게
물론 위치가 좀 더 좋은게
8천대
매각이 됐었는데 뭐 이것도 충분히
될 수 있다라고 생각을 하거든요 또
이제 건물 비용도 또 따로 받으니까
그리고 수익률은 마이너스 사실 이게
뭐 수익률이 이게 없죠 그냥 사옥으로
쓰는 거니까 뭐 임대로내는 거보다 더
좋을 수도 있죠 여기 등기부등본을
보면은
21년에 실행했거든요 그래서
모르겠어요 이게 변동금리를 하셨는지
아니면 3년 고정으로 하셨는지 그래서
아마 3년 고정으로 하셨으면 뭐 지금
모레는 뭐 문제 없을 것 같아요 그때
당시에는 그래도 이자가 좀 저렴했어
가지고
임대료내는 것보다는 훨씬 좀 괜찮으실
것 같습니다 지금
착공을
2021년 8월 10일 날에서 사용
승인일이 2022년 12월
26일이에요 1년 4개월 걸렸습니다
신축하는데 되게 오래 걸리죠
토탈로 따져보자면 설계가 제가 봤을
때 그래도 한 4개월은 걸렸을 거예요
최소 그래서 2020년에 샀는데
이제야 완공이 된 거예요 그래서 많은
분들이 이런 설계나 공사 기간을 되게
좀 짧게 생각하는 경우가 많은데
요즘 같은 경우 기간이 또 많이
늘어났어요
해체감리라든지 이런게 또 막 새로
생겨나기도 했고 공사기간이 생각보다
좀 오래 걸립니다 그래서 송은이 님도
한 1년
4개월 정도 걸린 거예요 설계까지
하면은 1년 6개월 거의 뭐 거의
2년 가까이 걸린 거죠
요거를 감안하시고 만약에 신축할
계획이시다라고 하면은
요런 기간을 좀 넉넉히
잡으셔야 될 것 같고
리모델링은 신축보다는 기간이 좀 더
적죠 아무래도 제가 예상컨대 한 반
정도는 줄어드는 거 같아요
그래서 혹시 만약에이 방송을
송은이님이 보고 계신다면
다음에 좀 기회가 된다면 내부 촬영할
수 있는
그런 허가를 주시면 제가 내부도
궁금합니다 이거 제가
외관상 봤을 때는
딱 들어가서 보면 지하도 너무 잘 돼
있을 것
궁금합니다 내가
직접
신축도 지어보면서 에피소드 되게
많잖아요 뭐 민원이 있을 수도 있고
아니면 뭐 하면서
여러가지 이슈 사항들이 있을 텐데
그런 것도 같이 좀 인터뷰 해주면
좋지 않을까 뭐 저만의 생각입니다
진짜 이거 연락 오면은 너무
좋겠는데요
연락 기다리고 있겠습니다네 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 그래서
계속 이렇게 좀 이렇게 유명인들이
매입한 사례나 뭐 이런게 있으면은
의견이나 이런 거를 좀
영상으로 담을 예정이니까
계속 좀 지켜봐 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다네 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다 감사합니다